hi there Steve Kaufman here it's the
23rd of December my wife has been baking
cookies and preparing for the Christmas
dinner tomorrow night all day long I've
been wrapping presents
but I want to talk about something that
came to me while I was wrapping my
presents
I think one of the most frequently
perhaps the most frequently asked
question from newcomers to link is where
do I start where is lesson 1 and I
usually answer it doesn't matter I say
you know pick something out your level
because in our library you can choose
beginner 1 to intermediate 1 to choose
something else your level choose
something you're kind of interested in
you can even look for content that has
translations because some of them do and
you can search for those items that have
translations to help you along but in
principle it doesn't matter and the
reason I sort of wanted to do a video on
that as I was as I was wrapping my
presence I was listening to Korea guess
what and I started by listening to
something somewhat difficult which I
didn't understand much of and then I
went back to our beginning series at
length who is she and eating out which I
have done quite a long time ago two
months ago and I think I even attempted
it maybe a year or so ago or two years
ago when I was in Japan and tried to
ramp up my career little bit so I've
done it supposedly I know it but in fact
I listen to it there's lots of words
that I don't understand so then I went
back to link and I started reading it
and of course all the words are either
white or yellow they're known or I've
been studying them but of course there's
words that I have subsequently forgotten
or never did learn but you know it's
wonderful to go over lessons that you
have done before and no matter how many
times I listen before certain things
would not stick and certain things
seemed strange is almost
if Korean as a language doesn't make
sense because the way they string words
together is to me when I first started
out quite a logical why would they write
it that way and now having struggled
with more difficult texts I go back to
my beginning lessons in a blink here and
and it really I feel that I'm learning
every word every word that I'd forgotten
because it's now so easy for me because
I pushed myself harder to go forward and
and I guess what I'm driving at is you
start somewhere in the language with
some lessons you're gonna have to go
back there again you should push
yourself to do some more difficult
lessons it's kind of anarchic and it's
not unlike the relationships it's like
like having a romance you know you don't
begin day one asking your partner where
was she born what does her father do you
know you got the basics like less than
one we do this listen to it's a matter
of you know it just comes at you however
it comes at you you have to deal with it
and then it's pleasant to go back and of
course there's an expression in French
oh well yeah to zoo I say pull me as I
move which means you already go back to
your first love but in the case of
language learning yeah you should go
back to some of the lessons you started
with and it's surprising how much more
you pick up on your second pass thinking
again of French poetry those the famous
ballad they dumb detours IDs where
there's the expression whose song don't
I think lineage don't I also don't pass
a lineage donto like where are the snows
of yesteryear
and of course the snows of yesteryear
are no more but when you're studying
language that's not the case because
your first lessons are still there you
can go back to them and you should go
back to them and I think I've mentioned
this before it's important very the
difficulty of what you're doing
don't try to ace the easy lessons at the
beginning because you won't be able to
keep forging forward creating a new
path in the snow so to speak but then
when you go back to that well trodden
path you'll find it easier and that's a
wonderful feeling and I think that kind
of pushing yourself forward going back
again that's how you learn and so it
almost doesn't matter where you start
because the language isn't it's not like
building a house with blocks it's very
much sort of a fuzzy learning experience
exposing yourself to this living thing
called the language developing a
relationship with the language sometimes
pushing the limits then other times
retreating back to where you are
comfortable and a combination of doing
these these things eventually helps the
language to stick with you so that's my
message here as a result of listening to
easy lessons in Korean while wrapping my
Christmas presents and if I don't do
another one which I probably won't
before Christmas I wish everyone a Merry
Christmas and you know there's a
sometime sub controversy I think it's
highly overblown but we're not religious
in any way at all but Christmas is a
very nice occasion where we get together
with family and we have a Christmas tree
and we have food and family and exchange
gifts and it's just a very pleasant
cheerful occasion and so to all of you
regardless of your religious persuasions
Merry Christmas and I look forward to
more exchanges in the new year thank you
for listening